turn
e
call door the uh September meeting for
the Health and Human Services oversight
committee when the clerk is ready would
role representative Pearson here
representative Weber representative
Edwards here representative King here
representative Merchant here
representative
Murphy representative
gray I'm here Senator Gray I'm sorry
Senator gray I do that every month
got my apologies represent McDonald
here Senator
rosenwall Senator avard
aard I received
uh I don't know what to call them
requests for leaves of absence from
representative M Murphy who's on
vacation in some exotic place and
Senator Rosenwald so they have been
asked to be
excused thank you uh we have minutes we
have to approve and we all should have
gotten copies of from May 24th and
September no September 27 we don't have
that thought we had June
June staple to May thank
you uh move to accept is there a second
discussion all in
favor I
opposed just to be clear I'm gonna stay
on the June 28th one okay I wasn't there
clerk so not thank you I know where you
were too where was I Wasing I was there
too
oh should have had the meeting
there
update Mr
yes I I see the agenda I I accept the
agenda I just want at uh the end of
before we finish I want to introduce an
important topic uh that we could um talk
about a little bit but really would
require um oversight U visitation of the
issue next
meeting I have just noted you into the
sir ready ready good morning um I for my
commissioner's update uh this morning I
would like to speak with you about the
Department's road map so what you have
in front of you uh is there's a a
two-pager uh back back side to side
which is sort of the clip note version
of the heavier packet of what you have
here um in color copy so
um you'll have the full detail um as it
is on our currently on our website um
and that we've been sharing but this is
uh one of the first uh chances to share
it publicly with this committee uh the
work that the department has prioritized
and will prioritize over the next
several years um if you recall last year
uh we had a road map we uh launched it
in terms of um looking at goals that
were important in that first 12 months
we've then taken that report in that
work and looked at as a collectively as
an agency as an organization our
directors our staff working together to
build this document that continues some
of that work and picks up some new work
uh but the similarities are that we have
a road map that basically highlights
three commitments which is what you will
see on this front page here so these
circles represent the commitments um and
they're described up on the very top as
the first is invest in people and
culture the SEC second is promote
thriving communities and the third is
improve customer service so we have
multiple initiatives and goals within
all of that and that's what you'll have
here in this
document but at a high level we know
that without our Workforce it's
impossible for us to do our job at the
department so it's really important that
we have a strong Workforce uh invested
Workforce well and that we have a
Workforce so in terms of retention and
recruitment that's what the focus is
here we look at some of our top uh
positions that have the highest turnover
rate um really Target those uh numbers
and bring those numbers down and also
increasing job satisfaction for our
staff um as you're probably aware a lot
of our staff have very difficult jobs um
and we want to keep them uh doing the
best that they can and and feeling that
they uh belong and are part of the
department so a lot of effort has been
made uh particularly by myself and my
leadership team to invest in our staff
uh to make those things happen because
promote thriving communities which is
the second commitment is a lot of our
policy work and our program work so we
need our Workforce to do that work if
you look at uh the circles I'll go off
of the uh two-pager here uh for the
promote thriving communities you'll see
things in there like Mission zero which
has been our initiative to eliminate
emergency room boarding um you'll see
things about environmental uh Health
impacts lessening that those those are
things like lead that we see in our
child care centers and and schools that
we've been working on um funding to
schools basically Medicaid to schools
making sure that schools have the
ability and the infrastructure and the
administrative in infrastructure to be
able to build for
that um we have uh I'm sorry did you
have a question oh I'm sorry okay okay
sure let me just go through this um we
also have our waiver which is basically
the successful transitions into the
community for individuals after
incarceration that's been a project
that's been worked on for many years uh
in collaboration with Doc so that folks
coming out of institutional care can
receive Services before they're actually
discharged and then um be in the
community and stay in the community and
reduce recidivism um and there's all
there's a lot more detail in the um the
packet itself um looking at our
children's behavioral residential Ser or
Behavioral Health System including
residential but all the tiers of
services for that we just recently
launched an overall assessment that's
system has been in place for a while
since be right around covid um and it's
time to look at and reassess uh where
the resources are are they in the right
where the utilization is the resources
are those all in the right spots so
we're embarking on that work now uh
Healthy Mothers Healthy Babies a lot of
that really about making sure of good
prenatal good postnatal uh postpartum
care as well uh we have our system of
care for healthy aging which is a very
comprehensive uh system that we've
launched uh last year with a lot of
deliverables um as well as the
developmental disability system which is
work that we've been working on for
years as well and we've had quite a
successful last year and um getting some
stability and then moving forward with
strengthening the system things
including rates and services so that's
that that promote thriving communities
is is chalk full of uh the bulk of the
work that we do but I will just say that
just because it's not in the road map
doesn't mean it's something that we're
not working on it these are the things
that we're sort of lifting up um a
little bit uh higher than some of the
other things um the last one is improve
customer service and when we look at who
our customers are we have internal
customers obviously but we have external
customers um so it's the it's the Soup
To Nuts on that one it's really looking
at you know who our partners are are we
able to not only provide the customer
service to the the people that we serve
but also the providers that we work with
are we able to pay bill on time are we
able to have good contracts do we have
interest from providers to partner with
us to do the services that the
department um is responsible to do
there's things in there about document
retention there's things in there about
responding to right to no requests and
and and working with that system and
making improvements there so a lot of
supon nut pieces on the administrative
backbone of it so that so that is like
my Cliff note like five minute summary
of of the road map that has taken us
months uh to to deliver we have launched
this in June um so it's relatively uh
fresh off the press there and I intend
to use this through obviously this
legislative upcoming legislative session
and budget hearings as well uh to
identify the Department's priorities and
where we're putting our
effort and on the back just before I end
um just a summary of you know again our
mission our vision and our values in
terms of the department so this would be
something that we could share you know
widely with our stakeholders so with
that I'll stop there if there's any
questions how many authorized positions
does DHHS have authorized I mean well I
mean not the people who you don't tell
us about just the ones that have been
approved by the
budget I think I mean you mean adjusted
authorized yeah I guess well we have
more than 3,000 but we can't go over
3,000 permanent permanent fulltime but
we don't have that many positions filled
well that's my next question so I want
to start with how many may you
have right now I only have a little over
2700 filled out of
3,000 3,000 is what I can't go for the
cap yes next question um given the US
Supreme Court's elimination of the
Chevron
deference um I was reflecting on that
thinking of the six years I was in
health and human Services committee and
the four years I've been chairing this
group that I've had a lot of interaction
with DHHS some of it uh during the
pandemic and found the relationship to
be very good I mean we didn't always
agree but we could talk we could respect
each other sometimes they took my point
other times I took theirs and sometimes
we agreed to disagree so I'm wondering
if um the elimination of the Chevron
difference what the ramifications might
be be for the
Department can I get back to you on that
sure privately
sure any other questions representative
Edwards um as you might uh suspect Mr
chair i' I've got several uh and I'll
I'll come back to you um okay all right
and and uh so commissioner Weaver i i i
routinely tell people uh when I'm not
around you that you probably have the
hardest job in New Hampshire you know uh
so so I I appreciate all that you don't
you tell her now that she's here huh I'm
I'm going to tell her that to her face
for once I think you have one of the
hardest jobs in New Hampshire and I
include the governor in that by the way
um so I so I have just some questions uh
to just make sure I understand where
where things are um I I think for
example on the mission zero um you all
established a completion date um that
was 2 years out from when you
established the date I'm just curious in
general are we on track to achieve
Mission zero or or are you expecting
there to be problems well just to
clarify it was one year I had one year I
woned two the court gave me one um and
that was this past May and we received
an extension um that we did not request
uh we received an extension until the
end of this calendar year for that but
within the last 12 months from May of 23
to May of 24 we've seen about a 50%
reduction in weight days time in
actually sitting in the Ed so we are
definitely trending in the right
direction um will we hit some days we
hit zero and those are days that we
celebrate loudly but the queue fills
back up the difference is is that the
speed and the efficiency with emptying
the queue is is quicker than it has is
is improved much more improved than it
has been for many many years so we have
all of our systems working together to
clear that queue every single day right
so so on a kind of a daily sensus sort
of way of thinking about it how many
patients on average do we have in an ER
hold awaiting more definitive
care yeah so that's it's it's not as a
black and white as answer of that when
we look look at the breakdown of that
because on Mondays it's higher than it
is on Wednesdays and Thursdays so I
could hit a zero on Wednesday and
Thursday I'd be really high but on
average probably less than
10 and and it and it had been as many as
40 or 50 right or 60 yes or so so that's
great progress may have a different
question hold that and um to what degree
do you have real control over this
because some of it is problems
Downstream that you would love to get
them out of the hospital and the
hospital would too but if there's
nowhere for them to go they can't go
there so
so Mission zero is comprised of six
strategies and one of those strategies
is discharge of where folks are going
after that so we are exercising our
ability and Authority within our
Authority for as much as we can control
and then working with our partners for
the things that we can't control to to
your point earlier is that we may not
control it but can we work together
collaboratively to to make some systems
Improvement and change and and we have
been okay there's still ways to go but
Merchant thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking the question commissioner um
on
the lavender under the promote thriving
communities one of the elements is to
reduce Health impacts of environmental
threats can you explain how the
Department's working with the Department
of Environmental Services because that's
kind of the link between health and the
environment and my specific question is
in CL mon we have
a possibility of having a transfer
station turned into a um actually
recycling center the transfer station
which would then bring a lot of heavy
metals into our community including
Mercury Arsenic and so forth along with
other things like Asbestos and my
concern is that those are Health
elements but they're really not under
the domain of the department but under
the Department of Health I mean
environmental services so how is DHHS
working with Dees in order to minimize
and try to accomplish a
strategy well I have no one from public
health with me here today at any level
um so I'm going to pinch in for them but
first of all you know we're located in
the same building Dees and public health
are um and that proximity is very
advantageous to working on these types
of issues so I will tell you whether
it's in the road map or whether it's um
a recall on lettuce um we work hand
inand with them on all of those
initiatives so in terms of what control
that we have we don't but we do have
influence and we do have voice with them
to be able to work together even though
if we may not be The
Driver
followup um if I could find somebody in
the Department of Public Health because
it's one of the things within the
community is really concerning to the
community because we're looking at
approximately 50 to 60 large trucks
coming through the community um there's
a school near where that location is
going to be within 1,000 ft um so
there's a lot of concern on the health
side about all these things coming
through the community as well as going
into that particular location so I'd
like to really talk to somebody within
the Department of Health Human Services
and what we can do to try to mitigate
that sure I will have the public health
director reach out to you um and and so
just so you know they may already be
working on on this but I will have Ian
wat reach out to you any other
questions I know just giving other folks
the chance representative Edwards
all right uh again thank you Mr chair uh
thank you madam commissioner I I want to
talk to you about uh for just a moment
one of these bullets I think you
mentioned was about building some
infrastructure around the school's
ability to do charging for their pupils
I I think I heard you say that which
which one of these bullets might that be
is is it the continue Federal funding to
local education agencies or yes it is so
so so this is the topic that I would
like to um um bring out and emphasize in
the next oversight meeting because when
we first started the um the clinics in
in schools program uh there was a fairly
clear understanding I thought at the
time that we were talking about two high
schools that parental consent was going
to be required for every interaction
between the student and the clinic um
and uh and that those requirements had
gotten into uh the contract I'm I'm I'm
hearing from people in the community
that they think that this is this
program has been subject to a scope
creep and they are concerned that uh we
are circumventing the parental notice
and approval process by um because of
federal mandates on the program and so I
would like to um have you come back with
the right team next month to to lay out
exactly how we started this program two
years ago and where it's at now and in
terms of its scope and its impact on
parental rights and and how this program
is being financed uh and and and where
your experts think uh it's going to be
in a in a couple years I mean how are we
trending so those are the kinds of
things I'd like to add to next month's
oversight um I will consult
representative Edwards with uh attorney
Edwards who's my schedule maker and
keeper as to where there might be a spot
either next month or in
November thank you um so I I don't know
if you want to say anything to what I
just said but I I have a different
question next
um how about we save it till we get on
the agenda so that we can get to your
next question okay
um I love this bullet about support
successful transitions in the community
for individuals after
incarceration so in the past week I've
gotten involved in talking to an
advocate for the disability
rights organization there's an A and I
don't know what their a stands for but
um the the concern
is that um that we haven't made public
yet what our census Management program
is going to be to try to keep residents
at the new cunu center and even
currently but but mostly the target I
think is the the new Youth Development
Center the concern is the the public
doesn't understand and I I don't
understand uh what active measures we're
going to be taking to to keep uh our
census at 12 and if it goes over 12 what
we're going to do you know to manage
between 12 and 18 um and then that 19th
patient I really need to understand what
we're going to do with the the the
potential 19th person that needs to be
in the Youth Development Center but
you're prohibited by law I think from
having them in there so I I I just need
to understand all of that and I think
the community needs to as well do do do
you do you think you could get people to
come maybe put together a special
presentation on the census management
for the Youth Development Center um sure
I mean it's it's it's active on our
radar it's active discussion I I just
want to kind of pull back a little bit
to be able to say that um what the
department can do in terms of
controlling census and what we have done
is if we think about the JJ
transformation juile Justice
transformation work that we've done that
is all about diverting kids out of
keeping them out of a place like senuna
center right um and we've seen a 50%
reduction in the last two years about
that so that's if kids don't need to be
there there doesn't mean they're not
getting Services it means they don't
officially become part of the system
which is what we want right um we've
averaged over the last two years about
16 youth in the facility so we know
that's that's where we've been we know
that our Target needs to be between 12
and 18 12 with the ability to go up to
18 if needed um in that space um but
we're actively working with courts and
gpbo and all of our teams and
stakeholders to come up with what is
that plan if that day arrives but I
think it's really about the version on
the other end of it before it is about
what do we do oh no they're here um but
happy to have more of a conversation
with you about that representative
Edwards you'd be happy to know that the
department has had very good
communication with the town of Hamstead
which I represent uh Dr hen has been
frequently available to answer the
questions and remember I live 300 yards
from where that new place is going so
I'm quite interested in this and I want
to thank the department for your
Communications especially the department
I think is been really great I mean
nationally we're first or second in
terms of the lowest per capita housing
in these scenarios so we're we're
already operating from a position of
great strength and great accomplishment
but I but but I think there's still this
need for the public to understand the
the active measures that are going to be
put in place around the census
management and and I think if if that
were clear a lot of at least some of the
consternation and the advocacy groups
would be you know mitigated and that's
kind of what I want to do is just have
us all get along sure I think you guys
are doing great we just need to make it
more public um and then uh if I more one
okay so
um you you I I love the fact that you're
referring to people as customers I think
that's the right framework for a
government entity to be thinking in
terms of customers so so I love that you
use the term you have internal and
external customers and I I agree with
that but I I'm just curious how you
define uh internal and external
customers just a little bit more sure so
our internal is obviously our staff our
own staff and within the agency but
there's 43 other state agencies we work
uh with many of them as well uh they're
also our customers for for different um
aspects of it as well as obviously the
people that we serve the legislature is
a stakeholder the governor's office is a
stakeholder I've got multiple
stakeholders in terms of what we do the
community is a stakeholder all of our
providers our advocacy groups uh parents
youth
everyone any other questions
representative McDonald thank you Mr
chairman uh under the customer service
uh category and I don't know if this is
something you you know right off the top
of your head so you can get back to me
if you need to but uh actually it's a
two-part question Mr chairman if I may
you may uh do you know what the off hand
the case loads for the um I don't know
if you still call them Family Services
Specialists and DFA how many cases they
currently have I know when I was in the
department it was like hundreds uh each
you know the the actual people who
administered the food stamps and and met
with the clients and so forth and also I
was curious about the workload of the
case load for the child protective
service workers in DCF uh how that is
right now too sure so I can tell you I
can get back to you with the exact
numbers for the family service
specialists but it is in the several
hundred uh range um and that is a little
bit different than a child protective
service worker who may be interacting
with the family every day where is with
the FSS workers that maybe uh the touch
points may be less frequent um I was
actually with uh two child protective
service workers yesterday uh as they
were going about doing their work and I
believe I asked both of them what their
case loads were and they were within the
limits of what they are which is uh for
assessment um I think she had uh 12 and
then Family Services is right around the
same 1213 area so they're within the the
bounds of where they're supposed to be
um of course that es and flows depending
on attrition and people having to pick
up cases when people leave but at least
the folks that I randomly spoke to
yesterday were within those limits and
when you look at our data dashboard
you'll see that as well I think in
aggregate we're within where we're
supposed to be for family services and
for uh for assessment um in terms of uh
the FSS case loads there really isn't a
uh standard for those case loads and I
know that having worked on that for
years in terms of national standards for
case loads they are high again and that
es and flows but I can get you uh a more
exact number on that follow up with you
I appreciate that but I one more
question one more thank you Mr chairman
um so of the 300 positions not filled
some of them in those areas um where the
fss's and cpsws are uh yes those are
some of the vacancies yeah I think we
have more vacancies on the fs side FS
Family Services side now than we do on
the child protection side just one more
you're on a roll yeah well
representative Edward has set the
example for me um in terms of
streamlining and improving customer
services uh service is is part of the
goal to try to reduce the case load of
some of these folks is that part of the
streamlining process or is that not a
realistic I know it's been this way for
a long long time so I think that's loads
I mean yeah I I don't I don't know if
it's um as explicit as you're saying it
in in the goal here but it is the it is
for every division to stay within their
policy parameters of what they're
supposed to have for case loads so part
of that is we're going back to we're
able to retain PE we're able to recruit
people and then keep people and then
they're working within the appropriate
uh standards that they have to be able
to do that so it is indirectly tied to
that but it's not as explicit in there
okay great thank you representative
Merchant you're welcome thank you Mr
chair and thank you commissioner I also
wanted to thank you for the report it's
well done thank you in regards to the
issue of personnel one of the things is
it mostly a question being competitive
in the marketplace with wages that are
causing a lot of the problems um can you
kind of what I'm trying to get to is how
do we as a legislative body help you
achieve what you're trying to achieve
some of it's going to be Financial so it
could be Regulatory and so forth but
what are the things we can do on our
side of the fence to try to mitigate
some of this because if we don't have
the Personnel a lot of things we want in
this report will never get accomplished
so what can we do on our side of the
fence to help you achieve what you're
trying to achieve no it's an excellent
question and I would like to say that um
and remind you this is multi multi-year
plan um
and I think you know going into this
budget year is going to be challenging
obviously right having a having a a cap
on how many employees I can have is is
challenging as well I mean part of it is
you know not even having enough staff
when when I started with the Department
27 years ago we had over
3,400 positions you know and now we're
down to like 2700 that's a significant
reduction in Workforce when we look at
other states comparable to New Hampshire
that with our Medicaid population we are
the most lean agency out of all of them
so we're doing a lot of work with
probably the
Staffing that we have so it's super
critical to to keep them um I'm going to
say I always want to have more staff
because I want to be able to provide the
services that we're going to need to do
so I think part of it is um trying not
to constrict the department and and
trying to get this work done when we say
what our needs are when they are in
terms of personnel uh salaries are
obviously always an issue right we just
we did have a significant increase
recently which is definitely helped um
and very appreciative for that but it's
still hard to compete with some places
that are paying more money for a less
stressful job if you think about the
work that the department does for our
case work this isn't like a widget job
or 9 to5 and you go home and you leave
it this is pretty intense work with
families the most vulnerable in our
state and it's hard to find people that
have the stamina of and and interest to
continue to do that so you know the work
conditions have to be right right it's
not just the pay it's the support it's
the good supervision it's the good
policy it's support from the legislature
it's all of
it follow up
thank you for that um can you sort of
help me understand how much of it is the
issue of the work itself which can be
stressful I'm sure versus the workload
which is connected to it because they're
really separate from each other um
sometimes if you have the ability to
decompress at times um you can get away
from sometimes the workload itself the
job becomes M more likely to be be
manageable so can you help me understand
is it really both the or how much of
it's the workload itself which is just
trying to do so much with so little
versus the job itself it's inherent to
it
it yeah I think that's you know that's
hard to that's hard to answer right with
a large Workforce that for some people
it is going to be the work load for sure
um our supervisors do a really good job
at trying to create those stress Outlets
or or coping or support outlets for you
uh for our staff and for some it is
going to be the work environment so it's
it's probably a little bit of boat but
both but I haven't really Quantified if
if so if you but that's going to
probably be some of the work that we do
going into this year that might tell us
more about
that if the commissioner uh is willing
um I am familiar with PTSD debriefing
through the fire department and so I'm
always concerned about the toll a job
takes on a person
individually I'm uh in discussion with
the Judiciary through the other hats I
wear about such debriefing possibilities
for judges who day in day out see
horrible things if you'd be so kind
maybe shoot me a brief email about the
nature of how your leaders do similar in
the DHHS that I can use as a side by
side with what I might like to see in
our Judiciary that would be very
helpful sure thank you anything
you 2024 New Hampshire Healthcare
quality and patient safety commission
up and bring
chairs and we really need to get more
than one microphone there yes good I
thank you Senator see this is an
engineer at work right there immediately
problem good morning you can bring
others up if you want oh thank you we
have a uh chairwoman in uh a new
chairperson who is here to observe who
will be coming to present next year so
that's her role so thank you for that
offer good morning everybody um we
really appreciate the opportunity to be
here to share with you the 2024 New
Hampshire healthc Care Quality and
patient safety annual report my name is
Chris Herring I'm the vice president of
quality improvement at the foundation
for healthy communities and I'm
administrator for the commission and I'm
Rory do diamond I am the patient safety
officer at Southern New Hampshire Health
in nshu New Hampshire and I served as
the chair of the uh quality commission
from 2022 through uh June of
2024 and you told me before you're
outgoing
I am so I will expect a great extrovert
performance I will do my
best I'm going to start us off and you
all have copies of the report in front
of you I hope if you
please I
did all
right I do of course if you
could thank you is this what we're
looking at I don't know because I don't
have it to look at it there it is it
looks like this thank
you um yep
it'ser no this has got a
St I think Senator it's the yep quality
and patient safety there you go all
right great thank you so much they
sometimes get silly yeah okay and we're
not going to read the report to you
verbatim but we just wanted to bring
some highlights to your attention um to
remind the group The commit the quality
and safety commission was first
legislated in 2005 and the purpose was
to provide confidential protections for
acute care hospitals to speak candidly
about Adverse Events and to identify
Improvement opportunities to make
patient care safer I do have to say that
those confidential protections are um
incredibly important and the group over
time has really learned to trust each
other and those conversations are very
rich for that reason it was made
permanent in 2019 and its scope was
expanded to include the 26 acute care
hospitals our four specialty hospitals
New Hampshire hospital Ambulatory
Surgery centers a design of the
commission of
DHHS and three at large public members
that represent the voice of the patient
which is very very important as we do
this work the commission meets in person
with a virtual option for extenda
circumstances feeling that in-person
attendance really does provide for that
information sharing and dialogue that is
so essential attendance at meetings this
past year was very high with 35 to 40
members on average
participating we use for guiding
principles to guide the work of the
commission and our agendas They are
promoting High reliability ility
organizations it's
imperative as the health care delivery
system is very complex and we need to
have systems in place that allow for
folks to be able to do things with some
standardization while also accounting
for safety in the face of unexpected
events we establish just cultures within
our organization so creating cultures of
safety where healthcare workers are
treated fairly when errors occurred and
system issues are examined and balanced
against individual accountability adopt
evidence-based practices to improve
outcomes and ensure Health Equity
diversion diversity and
inclusion in the 20123
2024 uh calendar uh commission
year there were review and discussion of
the most recent Adverse Events data
which is provided quarterly by New
Hampshire DHHS
like National Trend New Hampshire
experienced an increase in the number of
Adverse Events reported toward the end
of the federal Public Health Emergency
to remind everybody which ended in May
of
2023 as the hospitals and asc's returned
to normal operations and experienced
fewer Supply chains disruptions
refocused their quality improvement
initiatives and started stabilizing
their Workforce with less res Reliance
on temporary contract Staffing I'm happy
to to say the number of Adverse Events
decreased quarter over quarter
throughout the
year part of refocusing quality
improvement efforts included an emphasis
to staff and providers on the importance
of events reporting and reinforcing just
culture when events occurred to examine
system issues as well as individual
accountability as I mentioned
before factors that continue to hamper
Improvement efforts include ongoing work
force shortages as you heard from the
commissioner uh the healthcare Workforce
as you know is also experiencing those
longer lengths of stay for medically
cleared patients awaiting discharge
dispositions which create subsequent
backlog of patients waiting an emergency
departments High surgical volumes and
pressures on staff to move quickly and
less experienced staff who require
mentoring thank you Chris
so recognizing the challenges of the
healthcare environment the commission
focused on best practices to proactively
identify potential process failures and
identify evidence-based tools to assist
our clinicians in hardwiring all those
necessary elements for Quality patient
care so the report describes all the
focus areas but I wanted to give you
some highlights of a couple in
particular could you tell us what page
you're on if you are reading we are not
read you're not that's why I couldn't
find it no we're summarizing we we'll
give you time to peruse that take it
home thank
you so as Chris mentioned we are getting
quarterly updates from DHHS on the
adverse event report so we're being able
to review those more real time with our
uh commission members uh pressure
injuries continue to be the most
reported adverse event so our members
took a deep dive into the root cause
analyses and demographic data for those
injuries um pressure injuries are very
common in Healthcare Systems it's the
most common uh adverse event across the
country so those multi-disciplinary
teams are essentially to wound
prevention programs um as our staff with
specialty wound certifications which in
some of our hospitals particularly in
critical access areas they do not have
the ability to have those um so members
experiencing higher numbers of pressure
injuries described leading some rapid
cycle Improvement programs in their
hospitals to identify gaps in practice
and we are actually continuing that work
into this commission year as
well uh the second most common event are
patient falls with injury um so that
continues to be a major Focus for us as
well especially as the New Hampshire
population ages we have an increase in
dementia and delirium um so we did have
experts from John's Hopkins activity and
Mobility Program speak to us uh which
was very exciting uh they provided an
eight-step framework to increase patient
Mobility kind of the use it or lose it
perspective that when our patients are
in hospitals that we're continuing to
encourage them to be mobile which also
helps to reduce pressure injuries and
some of the other Adverse Events that we
see um we did see an increase in
surgical events particularly wrong site
surgery so that prompted another
in-depth discussion by all of the
organizations who had experienced those
events to look for some common causes uh
several themes emerged from that
discussion which will serve as guides
for our organizational Improvement
efforts going forward uh we were also
privileged to have the chief medical
officer for the Center for Clinical
standards and quality from CMS come and
speak to us uh to explain their
strategic plan and goals for federal
health quality measurement and that uh
the CMO engaged members in discussion on
how New Hampshire hospitals and ASCS can
be successful with those programs uh it
was very nice to hear that directly from
somebody at
CMS um as I mentioned with the updates
that we get quarterly we can be nimble
and quickly address emerging issues that
our hospitals bring forward um or that
come through our DHHS reporting um an
example of this was a uh when a member
who and uh New Hampshire State
epidemiologist Dr Benjamin Chan
explained their process for engaging the
CDC
uh to investigate and mitigate a cluster
of infections that were involving a
difficult to treat multi-drug resistant
organism that is not commonly seen in
this
better you're very welcome um so that
was very exciting the commission
acknowledges the importance of workplace
safety as well and its impact on quality
and we invited the newly formed New
Hampshire Healthcare workplace safety
commission and to discuss ongoing
collaboration with that team uh quality
leaders in the hospitals and the ASCS
play a crucial role in staff reporting
of workplace safety events and the data
collection and we also had uh input from
one of our public members who urged both
groups to include patient and family
interviews after an event to gain some
information from the patient perspective
in those events which was a a piece that
we don't always think about when we're
focused on our staff so that was very uh
important so as we enter our 20th year
uh we remain very grateful to the New
Hampshire legislature for this unique
body in addition to holding our five
regularly scheduled meetings in 2024 and
25 we're convening a work group to
address the pressure injuries that I had
commented on before and to further
identify resources and best practices in
between meetings to keep that momentum
going uh we've got ongoing collaboration
and education and we look forward to
continuing to drive those adverse event
numbers down throughout the state in the
year to come do you have any questions
for US Representative
Merchant just my thank you Mr chair but
are we talking about strictly this
report or this report into open with
this
one this one only correct we're not
talking about this report here at all
that's correct not yet thank you
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair I I have I have three different
questions um I'll come back to you um
the first one is uh really as much for
for Mr Williams as yall we talked about
it a little bit before the hearing that
there's another committee that got
established with the words uh quality
and safety in it as well that is the
responsibility of the department to to
host and I think I've been appointed to
that committee and and uh there's some
question
about whether or not that committee that
the Department's responsible for is
supposed to be meeting or if the work of
this Commission
uh obviates the need for this other
committee and so I'm I'm waiting for
Miss Tilly to come back it's been about
a month since I asked her the question
so I'm I'm hoping to get an answer about
the status of the of the other committee
with a very similar name
um second this is a real question uh
that the first one is more of a
statement but
the on um Health Equity and
standardization of care
uh completely agree with the objectives
and philosophy what uh has um uh left me
perplexed for at least two budget Cycles
now as I talked to the department about
their numbers is I don't I don't yet
have metrics on how we're measuring our
success and and if we can't measure our
success we can't measure whether or not
we have a problem I I I think
generically we can assume
that we have a cultural issue and there
are some health outcomes problems as a
result of of U race language the things
that keep us different than the same but
but unless we're measuring it and
Reporting on it we don't know whether or
not we're accomplishing our objectives
and so could you could you talk about
what metrics you're using and the extent
to which you're sharing those metrics or
the Department of Health and Human
Services is sharing their metrics with
you so so we know how we're
doing I take that or do you want me to
I'll defer that to you Chris okay um
thank you for the question and I have to
wonder if you work for CMS um so the qu
the answer to that question I wish would
be more simple but right now I have to
say it depends so hospitals are
currently doing the work right now
they're starting the work and they've
been collecting some data um primarily
race ethnicity and language for some
time um but they're expanding the data
that they're collecting um and starting
to look at
various patient populations and
examining that data to focus in on where
the disparities are so it's a work in
progress so right now currently I can't
say that that everybody's working on the
same metrics but the metrics are being
developed so I'd like to propose that
when we come back next year I might have
a better answer for you but that work is
being done right now individually by all
of our Healthcare
organizations third third question this
is a followup 2 a uh okay so um to be or
not Tob I think it's Tob thank you that
is the question
so
um the other thing that you may not know
is that uh monthly The Joint fiscal
committee receives a a DHHS dashboard
and that dashboard gives us a a bunch of
different categories of of data that we
should know about in the legislature on
how we're performing our our our
functions and I would love um and maybe
this is again for the Department I would
love to see that joint fiscal committee
dashboard extended so that we have some
metrics because I think we're assuming
disparity and that's a rational
assumption but until we can measure it
we don't know how to make investment and
policy decisions so so I think I think
we just need to like bring that out into
the open so that we can all focus on
understanding the real problem and and
then and then I do have my third
question Tito on to three Okay so um on
page six there's reference to drug
diversion prevention and um the
legislature for the last I think year
and a half has had a conversation with
the uh Governor's Commission on alcohol
and drug misuse um about um how to
incorporate the concept of harm
reduction into our commission's programs
and um and so as you're talking about
diversion uh I'm I I'm I'm I'm looking
at it wondering how this concept of harm
reduction fits into your Concepts and
what you think harm reduction is if you
if it's a factor that you're considering
in this in these diversion efforts so
it's kind of an open-ended question I'm
I'm just curious if you know anything
about the the on National debate on harm
reduction the state debate on harm
reduction and and how and and what your
it I'm happy to take an attempt to
answer that um so certainly as we are
discussing um drug diversion We are
continuing sorry I'm trying to look at
you through the speaker um we are having
those discussions uh we had a great
presentation this past commission year
on how we can proactively identify
employees that may be at risk and try to
interact with them and we do have uh
programs in the state to assist
employees who may be struggling with
substance use disorder um to get them
into a a path where they can address
that and not have to lose their job um
but that is something that we're
continuing to investigate and understand
a little bit more about I'm not sure if
that answers your question or
not it it it does answer my question
because what you just by your answer I I
know that the concept of harm reduction
isn't being debated and and argued in
your um in your commission um because
you didn't talk about the issues around
what what people are trying to do with
harm reduction so I'll I'll I I won't
poke at it anymore I'll just let you
know that there's a national debate on
on what harm reduction ought to mean and
what kind of limits government ought to
be putting on these harm reduction
programs and that's just for your
general awareness I I I appreciate that
you want to divert people from substance
abuse thank
you thank you for your
presentation but not yet representative
McDonald thank you Mr chairman believe I
heard one of you mention I think it was
you may on the left there uh the term
wrong site surgery and could you
elaborate on that please sure so a wrong
site surgery would be any surgery that
was not where we intended to go so
typically people think of the right knee
versus the left KNE um typically what we
find in the events that are reported
it's very common for spinal surgeries to
actually be I would say the most common
wrong site situation that we have um due
to the leveling of the vertebrae um so
that is our most frequent um concern
where a there's a certain vertebral
level that they meant to go to they went
to the level below that so that is I
think the majority of um the situations
that we've encountered I don't know if
you have any additional Insight on those
but
um follow follow up okay so it's not
when you say site it's not Vision it's
it's a location of the body a location
you representative Merchant thank you sh
um I noticed in the
report and I looked at the RSA it's
really focused on hospitals and amatory
surgical centers is there someplace else
in the RSA within the Department of
Health Human Services that focuses on
long-term care they call it hinant
because long-term care is also a
healthare setting um I'm just curious if
there's any somewhere else in this
department or within your organization
that actually looks at long-term care
care we would need to defer that to
good would you like to say I can stand I
um Chris whoops behind the light Chris
antelo associate commissioner yes um I
don't have the statute right in front of
me but I believe it is our licensing
151e um because we have our
certification and licensing unit that
looks at nursing facilities is there a
comparable report once a year like this
I will double check with um that unit
and I can get back to you thank you
you're
welcome thank you so much for your
presentation the chair now recognizes
Karen Hebert Community Services block
grant state plan
update good
morning I am Karen Heber director for
the division of economic stability for
DHHS
I am pleased to introduce to you uh a
couple of folks right behind me Mark
tremble who is the administrator of this
program uh an expert in it and also
Laura Ingram who is a finance manager
department so the community services
block
grant um is the subject here the
department as you may well know has a
responsibility to ensure access to
Quality community- Based Services for
eligible individuals and to protect and
care for some of the state's most
vulnerable
citizens the community services block
grant also uh a short
csbg is a federally funded Grant uh from
the office of community services from
our Federal Department of Health and
Human Services it provides funds to
States and territories and tribes to
administer support services that
alleviate the causes and conditions of
poverty in underresourced
communities csbg funds uh services and
activities that may include housing
nutrition utility and transportation
assistance uh support for employment and
education and other income and asset
Building
Services they can they may provide
crisis and emergency services and
Community Asset building initiatives and
other activities that would Empower
families with low Inc comes to become
self-sufficient New Hampshire is
required to submit a state plan for the
uh
csbg uh to the federal government every
two years in order to receive the
funding and the state plan assures that
the funds will be used to further the
goals and purposes of the act by
obtaining action plans based on
community needs
assessments and ensuring participation
in an accountability system and requires
a board of directors that is a
tripartite board made up of public
officials a representation from the
lowincome sector and the private sector
tripartite boards are also fully engaged
in the csbg development planning
implementation and
evaluation in New Hampshire there are
approximately
129,000 individuals that are served by
these programs each year
so DHHS uh receives this award and
contracts with the five community action
programs that are located throughout the
state and these support activities that
are designed to assist the low-income
families and
individuals um including those who
receive assistance under title four of
the Social Security Act folks who may be
homeless seasonal Farm Workers elderly
lowincome individuals
uh and activities that are uh to enable
families and individuals to remove
obstacles that solve problems uh to
block the achievement of
self-sufficiency uh it can also help to
secure and retain meaningful employment
and attain an adequate
education another purpose of the
contracts is to address the needs of
Youth in lowincome communities through
Youth Development
programs operationally the Caps
Community Action prog programs work with
the private sector and the state and the
counties local governments and other
nonprofits uh and their own networks to
reduce the causes of poverty the key
element to this particular Grant really
is community
collaboration through private donations
subcontracts M us caps continue to
coordinate services with the agencies
that are in their own service areas they
have representation on numerous board
boards and committees as well and they
work in conjunction with other social
service
organizations New Hampshire caps are
grantees of Li Heap Head Start
weatherization the workforce Innovation
and Opportunity Act and the tan of work
programs not all of the cap programs
work with housing and homeless or
Transportation or senior programs
however all five of them do have
Outreach staff and processes and
procedures in place to provide their
service
for those who are homebound or unable to
visit an agency in person the agencies
can assist them by phone mail electronic
communications or in some instances will
go to their
home each cap has conducted a community
needs assessment to determine the top
three needs in their
communities there are some Trends across
New Hampshire including substance misuse
employment challenge Alles and
housing but each region has its own
unique challenges and unique top three
each cap is working with their local
Partners as I described to create an
Innovative community-based initiatives
to address those top three
needs for example in belnap and Marram
counties that cap program uh is facing
challenges with dental services housing
and child
care top three for straford County area
is housing and homelessness substance
misuse and
transportation Southern New Hampshire
Services has identified Dental Services
food assistance and utility and fuel
assistance the Southwestern Community
Services cap has identified Community
Mental Health Services safe and
affordable housing and adequate
employment as their top three Tri count
cap uh has identified substance misuse
housing the funding allocation formula
for csbg funds is agreed upon by the cap
agencies in the state it's based on a
population and poverty levels that are
derived from census
figures with consideration given to
rural communities and changing
demographics the last award that the
department received which was fiscal
million and that's per fiscal
year so there is also a performance
measurement system uh and a a way to
track the accounting of the expenditures
of csbg funds uh including an accounting
of funds spent on administrative costs
and funds spent on the Direct Delivery
of local services this includes the
number of and characteristics of clients
served by the networ Based on data
that's collected from the
questions seeing none thank you so much
wonderful thank
you any handouts you might have for us I
have emailed of Representative King
ah good
joice thank you thank you thank
you now the chair invites to sit
down I almost called you representative
and I meant no offense um Senator maybe
uh Attorney John Williams uh chairman
Pearson and members of the Health Human
Services oversight committee for the
record I am John Williams legislative
director uh I am here to let you folks
know that due to unforeseen
circumstances uh the key presenter on
the next item involving our Ino report
on um Adverse Events in both the
hospital and ambulatory surgical care
setting uh is not available today uh you
do have a copy of the report uh and and
and attached to the report is the
contact information for the unit manager
so if you haven't have any specific
questions regarding the nine-page report
you can certainly refer to um Miss Doran
shley who is the manager for the program
I was able to reach out um in response
to also working collaboratively with
associate commissioner Chris anelo um in
response to the earlier question by
represent Merchant that the specific
reporting requirements and the report
before you um were developed back in
between like 2005 2010 time frame it was
represent P Pula who was actually the
chair of the committee at the time and I
actually had the honor of working with
him around this legislation and people
like Charlie McMahon also worked on it
as well it was very specific to those
facilities that were licensed under RSA
151 that related to both hospitals
ulatory surgical care settings so that's
currently what's in legislation and
that's currently why the report before
you uh gives you statistics regarding
those two particular settings now with
that said the um the centers for
Medicare and Medicaid services do
require for long-term care facilities to
take very seriously uh the issues of
Adverse Events as it relates to the
long-term care setting uh in our agency
even though we're not charged
statutorily to to provide similar data
that you see in this nine-page report as
relates to those other two licensed
facilities hospitals and ambulatory
surgical care we do follow up
meaningfully with investigations of any
reports for such things as a bedf fall
incident in those particular types of
facilities with our uh licensing folks
to conduct a review for those kind of
complaints so we wanted to let you know
there is a process in place to
investigate and to remediate those
actions but it's not built into a
similar reporting requir that you see
currently in statute as it relates to
facilities I thought I heard in an
earlier presentation that injuries this
is what I wrote down Etc decreased as
there are fewer contract agency temps
used I think I heard that did you hear
that were you out of the room I would
have to defer to the presenters who had
provided you that information
and would invite them to join
sure so that would be operative in this
report as well and chairman Pearson just
because we do have a viewing audience
here and it is being live streamed
uh through the house uh streaming if we
could have uh I think that was Miss do
diamond perhaps or Miss Herring if they
could just join us and just repeat that
answer just so the viewing audience can
good um thank you Chris Herring and um
chairman Pearson to your question I had
reported that through 2023 as Adverse
Events were decreasing hospitals and
Ambulatory Surgery centers had also seen
a decrease in contract staff would you
take that as coincident or
positive we were we came to the
conclusion that that was positive
positive I correct thank you thank you
welcome chairman yes representative
McDonald thank you Mr chairman
um it may be addressed in here somewhere
and I'm afraid I didn't find it yet if
it is what is a pressure
injury and chairman McDonald I I should
have clarified um at the start that I'm
explaining that we don't have staff here
to respond to questions on a report
however attached are the is the contact
information for who could address those
particular questions otherwise we could
work although you do have a very robust
agenda in October uh we could work to
having this carried over to the October
meeting to addressing these questions I
just didn't know if you happen to know
what it was I can take a venture or I
can refer to somebody else who might oh
I take
it Senator at risk of the New Hampshire
Hospital Association injury would be
somebody who was laying on their back
and because of that pressure uh there's
a preponderance for for sores and
different things so you're supposed to
be rotated and get you got to get up off
your feet and stuff okay
that is essentially correct yes it is
injuries to skin as a result of pressure
from a medical device or from the body
Lang on a bon P for a long period of
time well thank all we have you then so
so Mr chair yes I I I I hear Mr Williams
that there's no one here to ask the
question but but for the purposes of our
committee I I I want to I want to tell
you what I'm going to uh try to email
over to miss shley and that is I think
this report um is is is really good it's
a lot of data what would be nice is to
have some help so that we could
interpret it like for example we see
that the trend is up and that makes me
wonder if that's because there's U more
bad things happening or we're just
getting better at reporting I I think
it's probably a combination of both
because in previous hearings we've heard
that we're getting better at reporting
so for the record the team behind rep Mr
Williams is not affirmative to I I'll
finish in a second represent Merchant U
the the the other point I would uh want
to ask them is if they could uh
Benchmark these categories to uh similar
States because I I see a bar graph and I
I can see a trend but I don't know at
what point we we're dealing with sort of
um the the reasonable level of incidents
that happened because humanity is
imperfect or whether or not we we're
blowing through some benchmarks and we
got a real problem so so I could use
some help with some benchmarks and it'
probably be best to pick the five states
most similar to us and not New York
state for example or California you know
but but uh that would help uh interpret
this and then finally I I see uh in the
summary um that they've given a summary
but for a legislative report
uh they're not calling out in the
summary any major red light you know
they're not drawing our attention in the
summary to here's a problem we really
want you to see that this is a problem
we don't we don't have that in the
summary and I I don't see any suggestion
of potential legislation so so all of
those I think would take a very nice
data report and turn it into uh a report
legislators can interpret and use the
chair is going to rule nothing further
from the committee and make the
suggestion that if there are any
recommendations they be sent off to miss
shley and next month we might be able to
squeeze in uh something that addresses
these questions that were just raised
and any others that may be sent along so
squeeze it in
you review of new
2024 reporting requirements and other
enacted legislation related to HHS
oversight committee Attorney John
Williams director of legislative affairs
will walk us through several bullet
points we have here on the agenda about
things that I think are going to be new
for us and chairman uh pi and members of
the committee you may recall last
session or last year that I had come
before this committee and there were
twice the number of new reporting
requirements uh whether they were
reports to the committee review by the
committee review and approval by the
committee uh so you really had a very
sizable increase of over 12 um items
from last session um this year uh you'll
see that there were four uh bills that
were enacted into law that do touch upon
this committee there's also uh to give a
call out to rent Edwards he has IR ly
taken ownership of the HB uh 323
committee that deals with emergency
emerging medical Technologies and we
anticipate that there will be a report
from that one that's from
2022 uh but that's another example of
something that's out there in terms of a
report to this committee um I can turn
it over to represent Edwards if he
wanted to talk at all about that group
before I get into the five that uh were
okay so um it was a a bill um HP 323
passed in 2023 I believe that uh is a
year late on its inaugural report uh
we're going to have an inaugural report
that doesn't say much of anything other
then we think we should uh continue the
committee into the future uh it it does
have in the statute uh an address line
for HHS oversight so a copy will be
delivered
uh of this report to this committee um
but I don't but I don't know what
oversite wants to do with it whether
we're just going to have it sent to us
or whether or not you're going to want a
presentation on it and uh for this
inaugural report I I don't really think
it's it would be more than a two-minute
report but and I think I just kind of
gave it so um we'll take it as R and
look forward to the bill that would
really get this thing cranking
okay so we have we do have the first
report one October it's coming out we
can squeeze that in
somewhere and chairman Pearson
continuing on the bills that were
enacted this session the first of which
is HB
1168 uh it is a study committee a
legislative study committee uh that's
looking at the impact of the housing
crisis on those receiving uh
developmental services but also
individuals who have been um diagnosed
with with disabilities or identified as
having disabilities uh the uh study
committee has met um at least on three
occasions at this point um they're
working very meaningfully with the
Department with
stakeholders uh and uh our anticipation
is because they've identified the issues
as being very complex that they actually
have extended longitudinally their final
reporting date to November 1st of 2025
with that said there is an interim
report that's due to this committee and
other uh entities as well on November 1
of this year and our expectations are
that they've already identified some
meaningful work that perhaps have either
legislative or non-legislative solutions
to access for those receiving
developmental services to housing um
particularly I'm looking over at Senator
gray one of the um uh areas for housing
actually involves the around the
straford County area so certainly uh
very meaningful work is being done again
a collaboration with the stakeholders
working internally in our department
several program areas are involved
including uh associate commissioner
sano's area around long-term supports
and services uh and also with the legal
regulatory services around our Bureau of
Licensing certification and a special
call out also to the State Farm
Marshalls Office that's been
meaningfully working to try to address
uh barriers that might be um in
involving licensing issues to ensure
that those individuals get access to
housing yet maintaining some level of
Life Safety Code um uh protections for
th those individuals um do we see this
uh report being made to us in the next
one or two meetings it is anticipated
that with the tentative meeting in
November that that's when you would be
receiving the first um um interim report
I don't see it down here I'm probably if
you go to the first bullet um under HB
1168 you'll see inter report to be
I guess my question is I don't see it on
your draft agendas for the next two
oversight meetings and because we have
so many items if you flip the page over
you will likely see it oh
wow two pages okay all
right thank you and that takes us to hb1
1573 this is a companion bill to Senate
Bill
417 uh dealing with the oversight of
children in residential places ments um
chairman Pearson you were the prime
sponsor of the bill also you have
members of your committee here who also
served as co-sponsors and this is a
department um um uh item where we're to
be reporting on a quarterly basis uh the
first report uh on a quarterly basis
will be um honor before October 1st I do
know that that's being diligently worked
on and you will be receiving if you
haven't already that particular quarter
report so this would be up for a topical
item for the October meeting uh and
you'll see there is a series of uh two
additional quarterly reports with the
final quarterly report uh taking place
on October 1st of
2025 um it's good when you see a
termination of the reporting
requirements because it does take from
this committee at least some items off
your very long list of over 50 reporting
items um that come to your committee and
the list does grow um every session but
fortunately there are some that do
uh HP 1609 relative to the commission on
Primary Care Workforce this is actually
a commission that's been in existence
for well over a decade and this bill
essentially extended that commission so
it's not a new reporting requirement but
it is uh because they were scheduled the
sunset it was worthy of bringing to this
committee's attention the important work
that they do particularly on the area of
healthare delivery in underserved
populations underserved areas within the
state and you'll see that they've now
extended their interim and final report
uh as you'll see reflected here uh
November 1st of 2026 uh for an interim
Report with a final report of November
1st of
2029 it's not on your draft agenda for
that for me yet is it uh not quite yet
until 2026 sir um so that takes us to
sen up Bill 355 relative to newborn
screening for syto Megalo virus uh you
may recall this is a very important
issue to to Senator Enis um he had a
personal connection
uh with this very devastating um um
viral um conal issue and so it's one
where the department worked
collaboratively particularly the
division for Public Health Services to
having this addressed through our
existing Authority Under administrative
rules and so you'll see that there's a
reporting date of March 1st of 2025 that
will be coming back to this committee to
give you a status update on our efforts
to addressing uh Senator ennis's
concerns through our rule making so that
um pra uh providers are also looking at
this very important issue relative to
informing families uh if their if their
newborn is identified as having the
cytomegalo virus um that takes us
finally to Senate Bill 455 which is
relative to Medicaid reimbursement for
Prosthetics and orthodontic devices uh
that will be coming up on November 1st
uh Mr director Henry Litman who we all
know uh is just a wealth of information
will be here in November uh to talk to
you folks about the rate setting
requirements as it relates to these very
important areas for Prosthetics and the
orth orthotic um devices so that
completes the list of the five uh bills
that were passed this session that
touches upon this committee and I don't
know if you folks have any questions but
that concludes uh my summary and
overview we had earlier asked you to see
if we can put HB 323 about emerging
medical Technologies on next month's uh
agenda and amazingly when we turn to
page two it is suddenly emerged so it's
in the schedule for next
month for the record I was
chuckling to yourself to myself yeah any
Edwards anything else from the committee
thank
you I'm sorry are we meeting next month
we are meeting next month with a very
long agenda we are meeting on October
25th we also have scheduled a meeting
for November 22nd there are those who at
least for the time being have not chosen
to run again so I've already made a note
for someone to uh take over for one
meeting your job as able clerk but we
will be meeting in November uh
it
2128 it's not thank
you any other questions any other okay